the battle for the gavel still happening
on Capitol Hill and headed for uh 70th
vote hi kid we'll have more on that
coming up but let's get to this instead
America the adults are finally back in
the room after turning the border into a
broken turnstile and unleashing a record
wave of illegal immigrants Biden is now
here to fix it president will be
traveling to El Paso Texas on Sunday my
day off Dana to visit the border for the
first time in his 50-year political
career Biden was flanked by his highly
esteemed borders are to make the
announcement admitting that there's a
problem but refusing to call it a crisis
today I'd like to the vice president I'd
like to talk to you about uh how that my
Administration is dealing with our
situation in the Southwest border
Biden's big idea to stop the
never-ending flow of illegals just have
them down low been at download download
an app
down if they're seeking Asylum they can
use an app on their cell phone called
cbp1one cbp1one
let's just spell it out not the number
one to schedule an appointment at a port
of entry and make their Asylum claim
there without crossing the border
unlawfully and have a decision
determined by an asylum officer do they
qualify
and it wouldn't be a Biden press
conference without some good
old-fashioned Republican bashing
Republicans have refused to consider my
comprehensive plan
and they rejected my recent request for
an additional 3.5 billion dollars to
secure the Border it's clear that
immigration is a political issue that
extreme Republicans are always going to
run on we need more resources to secure
the Border yet again extreme Republicans
have said no the Republicans have been
serious about this at all I think he
just gave me covid Dana it's time for
you to take a little Victory lap around
this table but first I want to play this
clip of you predicting this that's what
happened a clip yeah
I do predict that Joe Biden the
president of the United States
commander-in-chief will visit the Border
in 2023. it will become untenable and he
will have to go there
so why did he why did it take so long
Dana and why did he do it now is it is
it because of what you said yesterday
that he's taking advantage of the chaos
I don't I actually think it has to do
with the fact of two things he's going
to Mexico uh for a visit and he's that
means that you're going to visit the
country where you're having all of these
problems on your Southern border and you
will have not have visited the border
that would be something that I think
that would just be impossible for them
to continue to ignore and the other
thing is I believe that they're getting
ready for him to Reena to announce he is
going to run for reelection in 2024 and
that not going to the border before that
would have been as I mentioned untenable
so I think those two things came
together I think it's fortuitous for him
that he's making this announcement in
the midst of all of the other chaos
which is the media loves to focus on
that and not so much on this I think
that they they've ignored the crisis for
so long that now that remember when we
said something had to change well what
changed in the media's mind when then
when did they start covering it it was
when Republican Governor started bussing
migrants to those cities and now you
have Mayors in Chicago and DC and New
York City and Philadelphia and then you
have the governor of Colorado so I'm
going to send more migrants to New York
and now this is becoming a democratic
problem saying wait we can't be the only
ones dealing with this this is a
national problem local resources are
being strained so I do think that made a
big difference I don't know if you could
say help is on the way for these border
states because it seemed to me like
downloading an app is really not going
to cut it when three million people have
come across the border there was hardly
any mention of the godaways and no
mention of the people who were caught
that were either have a criminal record
or were on the terrorist watch list we
have a major major problem and maybe if
I look for a silver lining and good news
is that because he's going they're going
to have to cover it and more people will
be aware of what's happening I wonder if
Joe knows what downloading an app is
he's probably assuming it's a potato
skins
what was that one thing they handed him
the phone and he played despacito that
was awesome
does any kind of
kind of this is now more a political act
than a patriotic one he was willing to
ignore a massive problem then agree with
Republicans and now he has to do it
politically yeah but it's politics and
if you look at the policy announced
today it's amnesty but it's nothing like
any amnesty we've ever seen usually we
give amnesty to people that are already
here illegally
he's going out to other countries and
giving them amnesty while they're in
their home country
and then they get to come here it's like
preemesty so you download an app in
Nicaragua and then you get on a plane
and you come here and then you're in
this is amazing I mean basically it did
nothing for border security it you can
still grab a kid any kid doesn't matter
who it is show up at the border and he's
going to let you in they're still catch
and release it just makes the process of
absorbing waves of illegals easier for
the government they're streamlining the
illegality they are streamlining the
illegalities turn the whole border into
a port of entry and
he has no legal authority to do this so
he's going to get hit with a ton of
lawsuits and that's good he says Mexico
is going to cooperate and he's going to
they're going to send some people back
so he's saying Mexico is going to take
the Caravans and he's gonna they're
gonna do a u-turn at the border and
Mexico is now going to send the care do
you believe that Mexico all of a sudden
is going to send the Caravans anywhere
of course not of course not this is a
bad deal and the Republicans in the
house once they finally get their act
together they need to step up and deal
with this well Harold first of all happy
New Year it's great to see you back at
the table it's good to be back yes it
really is uh how do you see a positive
outcome from this Republicans and
Democrats coming together perhaps I do
um indeeda well I didn't miss you guys
I've been watching the TV so it's good
it's good to see you good to have you
back Carol The Dana was right and I'm
glad she was right I thought I remember
when I was in Congress and President
Bush uh was the second half of it and
vice president Cheney you'd wake up in
at times and someone would be in Iraq or
in Afghanistan on a surprise trip they
did that because they for security
purposes I'm glad to see the president
going and I'm glad he announced it I
think there are four pillars here and
everybody has been right this
Administration has not focused on this
issue as they should in fact one of the
reasons they lost to Congress is because
of the lack of I think a focus and a
lack of a coherent policy here just so
you know that the Border you got to look
at fentanyl you got to look at the gains
you got to look at the human trafficking
you got to figure out ways whether you
send more law enforcement and border
patrols and you've got to support I hope
the president will make mention of some
of the things that they got wrong with
the the border security agency on the
horses that got mischaracterized with it
that it'd be great to push the reset
button two you got to figure out what
you do with Asylum that process down
there judge is so bad we have a policy
now words if you just show up at the
board and say things are really bad at
home we give you a hearing that has to
change we not only need more judges but
we need a better process not
streamlining legality but streamline who
can come in and why they can come in
three you gotta you gotta make clear are
some certainty around workers and
students we have a worker shortage in
the country but we shouldn't Grant
amnesty to everybody we've got to make
that clear people who went and stood in
line and did this legally it's got to be
a total affront to them and their
families that people are able to get in
like we're allowing people to get in and
finally the Mexico trip Dana you're
right the hemispheric buy-in has to be
there Mexico is not going to take
everybody but remember we had this
policy under President Trump A variation
of it we need something smart like that
and for perhaps even more Visionary
going forward so I I've criticized the
administration for this in the past I'm
glad he's going there and I hope that
there's a willingness once Congress gets
in for Republicans to put pressure on
the president and for the president to
put pressure on them and for us to get a
policy that makes sense and makes us
safer lastly judge two Heralds of
diplomatic point should we just accept
the fact that better late than never and
applaud Joe Biden for finally coming
around to admitting that we were all
right
you know I it's it's very hard for me to
applaud Joe Biden and I'll tell you why
the speech today pretty much says it all
the speech that he gave today a quote is
the process is orderly it's safe and
Humane and it works this guy is going to
Gaslight us when he goes there he's
going to talk about how great it is he's
not going to talk about the mess and you
know Harold no one agrees with you more
than I do at this table that he has to
look at the gangs look at the fentanyl
look at the human trafficking but if you
deny that If you deny that it's even
occurring if you allow it to occur if
you do nothing about it when you know
it's occurring then you are complicit as
far as I'm concerned and if you look at
it that's fine and dandy but until you
tell me you're going to give money to
border patrol you're going to make sure
that there are arrests for fentanyl that
there that this cashless bail where
people arrested for fentanyl illegals
are released immediately until you
change those laws these people are still
entering as got aways so it's all talk
and you know Miss Kamala behind him
who's there for the root causes I must
have missed the report I don't know Dana
maybe you got it I didn't see it yeah I
didn't I didn't see it either but the
truth is that I believe that the
moderate that the Democrats who were in
trouble this last midterm said Joe you
got to go down there if you don't go
down there we're all in trouble and
that's why even now Governors like the
one in Colorado Democratic governor is
is now pushing illegals out of his State
because he doesn't want him either so
this is a situation where his own party
is forcing him to go there saying how
dare you this is an invasion of the
Southern border of people we know
nothing about MS-13 Latin Kings fentanyl
killing 100 people A Day in the United
States and your la dee da da don telling
us the board is secure nonsense until he
proves that it is secure I don't believe
a word he says
then I add one thing those because I
think this is important for you viewers
to know if in case you missed it today
because there are the moderate Democrats
who are saying that but then there are
very prominent powerful Democrats like
Senator Menendez of New Jersey yes who's
the head of the Forum Affairs committee
right is that the chairman of the
Foreign Affairs committee so any
legislation would have to go through
that committee I'm assuming he says that
Biden's suggestions today are racist
that he thinks that this is a terrible
thing he wants the president to go in
the other direction from Republicans so
the people people in Washington
representing all of us are very far
apart on this issue well actually I
think there's probably more agreement
for what we are suggesting but the power
Senate it will be a bipartisan vote for
foreign
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now